Beth Roden what are small things that
everybody can do to improve their
quality of life regardless of income
okay I have a few thoughts on this now
every single one of these is going to
assume something and I get that I don't
know that there are any total universals
but here's a few ideas
number one exercise some kind of
exercise particularly that takes place
outside now if you are not physically
able to walk around then I still think
being in the outdoors is a good thing
and maybe there's some way for you to
sort of achieve that right so some kind
of regular exercise and exposure to the
great outdoors even if you're in a city
even if it's a concrete jungle I still
think it's very very good to be outdoors
and it's been shown to significantly
improve cognition decreased depression
etc etc some degree of mindfulness
meditation now it doesn't have to be
some sitting cross-legged for three
hours with you know your fingers crossed
and what it right but whatever the case
may be even just sitting for 10 minutes
twice a day with no agenda just sitting
that's it that's been shown to be really
really good for both sort of emotional
health and quality of life and maybe
even connections to physical well-being
so I think that that's something that's
really good I think it's a really good
idea to pay attention to hydration I
mean it's kind of crazy right but tons
of people just aren't drinking enough
water I'm not in the camp of you should
be drinking 15 glasses of water a day
like some people say but a lot of people
don't realize that they're dehydrated
and staying hydrated is something that
everybody can do I mean I know that not
everybody in the world has access to
clean water sadly so again there's no
universals here but most people in the
United States do have access to water so
those are a few things that come to mind
to me yeah I think exercise is a big one
not only for your physical health but
also gets those endorphins pumping in
your brain or you feel better how about
even just like when you're doing
monotonous tasks like chores around the
house if you have if you're listening to
something be it like you know some new
or like an audiobook or something I
think that really increases my quality
of life does it really it does
interesting we've got a film Pat and see
what it is he's got going on while he's
listening to these various audiobooks
maybe a tutorial on how to make cured
coffee
yeah curing to toriel or whatever you're
doing yeah one other thing is what about
reading right I think that there are
books that will appeal to everybody a
lot of people just say I don't like to
read it doesn't hold my attention that
means you just haven't found the right
books I do believe that there are books
that will appeal to everybody it doesn't
matter what they are even if you can set
aside 15 minutes a day just to read
something fiction or nonfiction a book
right I'm not talking about a magazine
or online articles or text messages or
whatever find 15 minutes to read I think
that that does a lot to improve quality
of life yeah I always have some inner
peace after reading for a little while
and I feel a lot more connected to the
human experience really and I find that
I just start thinking about things a
little bit differently after I read for
a little while what's Pat reading that
he's having these enlightened
enlightening experiences every time he
cracks a book but we really need a
documentary I think to figure out what's
going on over at Pat's place those are
some ideas all right I think that those
are all really good things and being
social I think being social and again
what that means to everybody everybody's
ability to do that is different but it
doesn't have to cost money to be social
and whether it's friends family whatever
seeing and talking to other people
that's a good thing isn't it that's why
we're talking about this now we're
talking about it right now absolutely so
those are my ideas all right thanks to
everybody who wrote in this week we've
got a great bonus show coming up for you
where is NASA why are private companies
now getting involved in taking us to
space instead of NASA we will talk about
that we will talk about the possibility
of life-saving drones in emergencies and
we will also talk sadly about American
traffic fatalities rising again what's
driving that change you'll have to tune
in to the bonus show you can sign up at
david pakman.com slash membership or you
can access the bonus show by becoming a
$5 patron at patreon.com slash david
pakman show I'll speak to you then